what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
seven prediction video today I want to
talk about something that has been
debated over ever since season six ended
and that is the current state of the
relationship between John and Sansa I
feel like The Game of Thrones community
has split down the middle when it comes
to this topic
some people say John and songs that will
have a healthy relationship moving
forward and others say they will have a
rocky relationship moving forward I have
discussed this briefly in one of my plot
league break down videos but there were
a lot of other things that discussed the
neck video so the comments weren't
dedicated to this discussion so I
figured I would make a video about John
and songs only that way I can get a feel
for what the majority of you think about
this so I'm going to need everyone's
opinion how do you think their
relationship will play out in the
upcoming season
well songs just stand by John as king of
the north will she try to position
herself to have the power it's no secret
that John and Sansa have bumped heads
throughout their life in fact one of the
first discussions they had when they
were reunited was about the way they
treated each other as kids but this
dynamic is so much more important and
serious now that they have so much power
right at the end of their fingertips and
they both know who is the rightful heir
at this moment and with Littlefinger in
the background manipulating Sansa this
could potentially turn into a very
dangerous situation depending how you
want to look at this I think where most
people struggle with this relationship
is based off who people feel has the
true rights to Winterfell in the North
songs of stark is the true born daughter
of Ned and Catelyn Stark
whereas Jon Snow is just a bastard which
typically removes most rights to lands
and titles although he is the oldest
remaining male in the family and what
else makes this a tricky situation is
the fact that bran Stark is still alive
but no one knows that yet Theon did tell
Songza that he didn't kill bran and
Rickon but they have no idea if he is
still alive at this moment in time but
that would be another argument for
another day right now the tensions are
rising between John sons and
Littlefinger after the Battle of the
bastards was won shawnzy gave the
impression that she would now stand by
Jon Snow and his place in the North
songs had told John that he was a start
to her and she even told John that he
should stay in the master bedroom in
Winterfell and she also apologized for
not telling John about the Knights of
the Vale
John had no idea they were coming and if
he had this knowledge perhaps he could
have changed his battle strategy and not
have law
as many men but John forgave her anyway
because I think he was just happy to
have won the battle and have their home
back but he did tell Songza that they
need to trust each other because they
have so many enemies now which is true
once again Littlefinger was back to
playing his games by trying to
manipulate sons into distancing herself
from John Snow and his position
Littlefinger told songs of that she is
the true born daughter of the Starks and
John is just a bastard basically saying
that John has no right to be in charge
thanks to Psalms and Littlefinger they
did save John from losing the battle and
his life when he went up against the
Bolton's but is that enough for songs
that had all the power in not John this
is where the debate starts to get heated
and what takes things over the top is
when John is named king of the north
while songs I got no love or recognition
from anyone during all those speeches as
John was rising during the king in the
north tant
songs and Littlefinger exchanged a look
that can be interpreted in many
different ways in my opinion when songs
I looked at Littlefinger that way I
think it was a look of concern and she
was wondering what he was going to do
next because it was obvious that
Littlefinger wasn't pleased with the
decision to name John the king and we
all know our little finger feels this
way with John being named King this puts
a roadblock in front a little finger in
his master plan Littlefinger feels that
if Songza has the power in the north he
will have a better chance of being able
to influence the decisions that she
makes which would typically be true but
what John as king in the north
Littlefinger is powerless unless of
course he used the Vale army to try and
take over wonderful for himself but
there is two sides to this coin when
Littlefinger and songs I shared that
look other people believe that this is
sons a more or less acknowledging the
fact that Littlefinger might be right
about John and this is where they think
there could be some problems in the
north between John and Sansa
Sansa definitely deserves some
recognition but the scene ended before
John was able to say anything I think
when season 7 starts we're going to jump
right back to this scene as Johnny
standing up as the new king in the north
and in my opinion I think John will say
something about Shawn's just like he bit
up on the roof when he told songs as she
was the lady of Winterfell and they
wouldn't be standing there if it wasn't
for her I believe John will give her the
credit words do John may even say that
Songza is the lady of Winterfell again
in front of everybody we just don't know
how this is going to play
because they ended the scene like that
so we would debate over this during the
entire offseason even in interviews
Sansa has hinted at her having issues
with John and the upcoming season but I
don't think it's going to be as serious
as some people may think if John doesn't
stand up and show her any kind of love
in front of everyone then she definitely
has a right to be pissed off but I think
John will do the right thing and say he
wouldn't have won the battle without
Shawn's his health I think in order for
Saunders character to complete her art
she can't continue to let little thinker
manipulate her and set her character's
progression back she already told Jon
that only a fool would trust
Littlefinger and she already turned down
little fingers pretty little picture of
him sitting on the Iron Throne
with her at his side Shonda has been ran
over by Littlefinger enough she knows
the game and she knows what he wants
it's time for songs at I'll play
Littlefinger at his own game I do not
believe songs are will try and conspire
with Littlefinger to overthrow Jon or
anything like that I'm not even sure
songs that still wants to be queen I'm
not saying she would turn it down but I
don't think she's actively seeking it
and I would be very disappointed in
Sansa if she allowed Littlefinger to
talk her into removing John from power
it songs actually sat down and had a
serious conversation with John about
this I don't think John would give a
[ __ ] about having the title as king
the only thing John is worried about
right now is defeating these damn White
Walkers if they don't stop with all the
[ __ ] and stick together for this war
against the others no one's going to
survive to even sit on that damn throne
so to basically summarize all this I
think when season seven starts and we go
back to the scene in the dining hall at
Winterfell we're going to see John
standing up after they Chaney King in
the north
and I believe John will show signs of
the credit that she deserves we all know
John is leaving next season it goes
south which will give little things at
the time an opportunity to get insan to
set once again but I think songs are may
pretend to go along with Littlefinger
but ultimately songs that will checkmate
Petyr Baelish which will lead to his
execution it's a time for wolves my
friends the lone wolf dies but the pact
survives now is the time that Starks
band together and put everything and
everyone else in their way to rest the
comment below and tell me if you think
John and Sansa will have a healthy
relationship or do you think Songza will
start to build up some resentment and
want to do something about it let me
know your thoughts on this topic down
below thank you for stopping by today to
watch the video I appreciate each and
every one of you
show support and a big thanks to my
patreon supporters I love you all and
I'll see you down below bye